I feel like my tongue is gonna start not
being able to articulate what I want it
like forwards its where should I keep
going
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by EDM s class clown
Dylan Francis you know him from his many
hit records and remixes as much buzzed
about stage shows and he can catch him
alongside james van der beek and vice
Leon's what would Diplo do check your
local listings Dylan welcome to the show
thank you how are you a spicy food I
think I'm pretty good but I could be
completely wrong this show is really the
test of that yeah we'll see where you
fall yeah that's that's why I wanted to
be on here also just because I saw the
DJ snake one and I was crying laughing
oh well that's actually a poetic segue
to the first wing I love when that
happens you ready to go yeah let's do it
[Music]
then you got to eat the whole wing right
so there are no rules I think you got to
make sure hard rules yeah yeah so for
years I know that you've been involved
in a bitter back-and-forth prank war
with DJ snake and when he was on the
show he told us about how upset you got
when he put your cell phone number
up on the big screen at Ultra I wonder
what that experience is like from your
perspective and what did you do to
retaliate it did suck because I remember
the number was 4 2 4 3 3 3 6 8 9 2 and I
just loved the number it was so easy to
remember and then he ruined my life
my phone battery was gone in one second
because I was getting so many text
messages from people at Ultra I guess I
did kind of prank DJ snake back as well
where we put his face on top of like a
male porn star and you know had the
giant eyes yeah they had the junk out
but digitized it so you couldn't see it
and he was fine with that he was
laughing but I did it to Martin garrix
one time at this festival in Amsterdam
and he he called me and he was pissed
well Martin so sweet I know how can you
do that to Martin I don't know I'm just
like I think everyone has my train of
thought where it's like if you see that
image or go back that's so funny but he
was like dude my parents are at the
festival like you can't put up images
like that they're gonna think it's real
funny story actually the way that I've
like really connected with Skrillex I
was at South by Southwest I feel like it
was this sauce i dabbed it I had to take
my shirt off and hold it against my
mouth it gets like that's it was awful
yeah so in your merch shop you sell
everything from t-shirts to branded
fidget spinners it was caught my eye is
the awesome [ __ ] tab where you sell and
I don't want to make sure I list some of
these off we'll do a fans taxes for
7,500 bucks
absolutely you'll go vegan for a year if
someone Forks over 150 grand I just want
to look good
you'll put together a fan's IKEA
furniture for 10 stacks or he did that
that was gonna ask has anybody ever
called your bluff and pulled the trigger
on whoa yeah Jesus built IKEA furniture
for
I think it was Huffington Post they
bought it because that was like the only
way we would do an interview with him
and then I'm trying to think of what
there's oh yeah some other a mom coolest
mom ever bought babysit your kid so I
came over and and I did like a whole
babysitting video with him
what if somebody forked over $25,000 to
ruin their stepdads Christmas how do you
think you'd even do it I would just home
alone it I think I'd probably do like
exactly what's in the script for home
alone two paint cans come on down
marbles out of the hardwood floor whole
thing stepdad would not want to be there
anymore
[Music]
yeah I'm scared I really want to get to
the last stab I think you'll make it do
you think so I can see the eye of the
tiger so before we move on I just want
to say you're looking Jack dude and I'm
happy that we could help you with your
protein intake today are you still doing
crossfit we're going out on your fitness
I've been so bad lately could you do a
handstand push-up or what do you think
the most impressive thing you can do
physically nothing I can stand on top of
a DJ booth and like wave my hands like
this and jump up and down exactly how do
you think Skrillex would do in a
CrossFit class do you think he'd make it
through on ramp we did it we did one
actually together he did well he liked
it but then I don't think he ever did it
again the thing about CrossFit is that
the people who do CrossFit never shut
the [ __ ] up about CrossFit from somebody
who is on the inside what do you think
it is about that group workout class
that people connect to so powerful I
think the reason a lot of people talk
about it so much is because they want
all their friends to do with them it's
almost like Game of Thrones I don't
watch it but so many people talk about
it and then they make you want to like
have to feel like you need to go and do
it or watch it so you can be a part of
like the little clique some common
ground yeah I mean I came here alone you
know so [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[Music]
how many wings do you think you eat a
week so this shows weekly so that would
be like at least ten wings and then
anytime anybody wants to do anything
with me it always involves two big wings
uh-huh the whole thing for me it's
always like do something funny right for
the for a picture that's my favorite
when someone's like hey let me get a
picture do something funny what the [ __ ]
do you do funny in a picture like this
not bad
alright yeah but everyone just just been
done right right right I don't know what
else to do anymore
and then to you feel like a seal
balancing a ball on your nose I know and
then it's like listen nobody wants to
complain about celebrity lifestyle but
listen there are some pitfalls to it is
I don't know what you have to do funny
things in pictures yeah constantly I
just need to start taking my dick out
that's the move that's the move that's
the move that's it so back in 2012 your
tour rider leaked online and it made
some headlines cuz you had some
interesting things like a signed photo
of a vici a bag of jasmine rice a
blow-up doll you're forgetting a lot of
the really good stuff on there though
what did I miss what it done black tar
heroin Lube Lou the blow-up doll
naturally and the reason I bring that up
is because that's all a joke of course I
don't want black tar heroin but we were
going through we were going through
Canadian customs and the promoter put my
writer in the customs form oh so they
found it and this is when floss was
touring with me we got woken up at like
4:00 a.m. and that we're all sitting in
the customs or anything and and the cop
comes up and he goes am i gonna find any
child pornography on the bus and
everyone looks at me and they're like
what the [ __ ] did you do
who the [ __ ] are we touring with I don't
know why they assumed there was child
pornography on the bus right because I
did ask for assorted genres of porn but
they went straight to like the
disgusting part and I guess it's cuz the
gun and black tar heroin that's you know
they were just going you have had that
you paid yeah exactly and so then
everyone looked at me as they left and
like what is on your writer and I'm like
I swear to God not kid porn but like
there's a gun and harm
and heroin so they went and they tore up
the bus and they also took a [ __ ] on it
which we had to pay for and you're not a
lot of [ __ ] on buses if anyone doesn't
know that so this one is the hot one
sauce you're on the hot Larry show away
mm-hmm let's do it
ooh that's good all right done well we
have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that Graham where you a
deep dive on our guest Instagram pull
interesting picture that need more
context so I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture then you can tell
me the bigger stories that's I'm good
let's do it
all right first things first
world famous DJs have the best Instagram
accounts and this is a perfect example
of it with the fireworks waterfall
behind you sometimes I don't even know
that think that we have anything did the
pyrotechnics and stuff do they ever
catch you by surprise yes definitely
there was one at Red Rocks where I was
standing on the booth and it started
going and it was so close to me I was
like oh [ __ ] and so I got off
immediately I'm just a tired person all
the time so you get the notes about
what's happening you kind of glance over
it they know that you're in danger until
you're like until I'm where I live
that's so funny because that's exactly
what I do I'll glance over something
very cool nobody oh that oh that was in
the email yeah my bad hanging out with
Dillon Francis superfan Kate Hudson it's
a good friend of mine I had known that
she was friends with Diplo and she was
listening to coming over one of my songs
on Spotify right now actually just
reached a hundred million on Spotify and
no one will send me a plaque cuz I
thought that was a really big
achievement but no one else does because
all these [ __ ] [ __ ] pop stars are
like getting way more streams yeah and
my accomplishments are just diminished
no I so it's so shitty I think about
that sometimes
I'm gonna go off-topic here for just a
second but this is what I think about
like we're just on like the little tip
of the You Tube yes but sometimes you
dig a little bit deeper and I see all
these like conventionally attractive
young adults just doing diss tracks to
each other and then all of those videos
have like 100 million reviews it's like
crazy like we're little or nothing
ants on the bottom of your shoe and then
that's gotten to a point where they've
kind of actually eclipsed like actual
real accomplished talented artists less
if you want to get into that we can go
let's get into that okay I'm also just
older though I'm not from that
generation so maybe I'm just being a
hater we're both a little out of time
exactly but like when you see for
instance cassava Steen's music video for
pursued I don't know how many views it
has on on YouTube hopefully way more
than most vlogs probably not though
doesn't have like 16 million and cassava
see probably has maybe 2 million right
but it's a work of art like really
incredible that it goes so well with the
song so it is it is kind of like man
[ __ ] maybe I should just stop doing fun
a stop hard yeah why not try are we
trying so hard I don't know we got a
stop to waste the time you should just
start filming ourselves clipping our
pubes just doing our daily lives and
that and we're gonna get millions of
views oh there you go there's a heat
there it's coming it's finally here you
got four more mm-hmm okay I see you so
one of the things that I like about you
most is your willingness to poke fun at
EDM festival culture and the like
through these alter egos like DJ Rich's
[ __ ] and Hansell welcome to how you say
what's on soap you hairless flostor
Damas every single thing ever done
what's something that you hear EDM fans
complain about that makes you roll your
holes
okay that's I like that this is
something that actually pisses me off a
lot and I think it pisses off from a lot
of artists where fans will always be
like man I missed the old Dylan Francis
but jay-z's already talked about this a
long time ago orts listen to my old
music you'll be happy again but it's
it's obnoxious when those fans keep
saying that to any any new release and
then if you release something that
sounds like the old or
of you they'll just say oh this sounds
like the old version of Dillon Francis I
don't really like this that much I try
not to complain anymore even give it the
time of day where just like alright cool
go and complain in a thread on reddit I
don't care
let me bring up something that comes up
with EDM all the time because a lot of
people say you know maybe models or
celebrities the leverage the big-name in
order to get that DJ spot rather than
having ability or talent do you think
that that's something that's a little
overblown is it a legitimate criticism
what do you think about that yeah I just
don't think it really affects a music
producer just because I think we're in
we're you know we're still part of a
musician world right even if Liam
Gallagher doesn't think we're cool who
do you respect more as an artist Paris
Hilton or DJ Pauly D from Jersey Shore
what you can't do that that's tough holy
[ __ ] oh man
probably Paris Hilton right I don't I
don't think there's a right answer to
this one
have you ever just like drank milk
before doing the hotter ones so t-pain
had that as a strategy didn't work out
it didn't seem too
[Music]
so I feel like now is as good a wing as
any to talk about your IMDB page because
what would Diplo do premiered last month
I'm finally an actor and you're actually
in a movie called Scouts guide to the
zombie apocalypse right Neverland
Francis was seeing your head explode on
the silver screen a bucket list item yes
absolutely
and when Chris Landon told me that I was
so happy because I was like yeah yes
what would be a bigger thrill for you
hosting Saturday Night Live or winning a
Grammy Wow I would honestly want to host
Saturday Night Live
cuz that's I grew up sorry some of that
hot miss got in my throat and stayed on
the topic of TV on The Tonight Show
Jimmy Fallon and Chris Rock they had the
not playlist segment yeah Jesus yeah and
they went after you Dylan friends yeah
what do you think of that I loved it
this is hot
[Applause]
trying different ways to eat it mm-hmm
smart it's so weird that do people
normally eat this like there's some
person actually eating this every day
and what is it doing to their intestines
I could speak to that but you know I've
met so many hot sauce badasses doing
this job you know like nothing I ever do
is ever hot enough for anybody I can't
satisfy my hot sauce with what bus so
many people do it I put the bomb on my
eggs oh you're not that big a deal but
that seems to me like a chaotic person
milk and chicken is weird
mm-hmm-hmm but you know you got to do
what you got to do to survive here oh
this one sauce mm-hmm it tastes like a
piece of [ __ ]
common to Blaine comically oh my god
milk and chicken is fantastic yeah that
one sucked holy [ __ ] my tongue is on
fire yeah
yeah and you say sucked and sir these
past tense but you're now in the minute
you're in the soup I'm in the soup at
the bomb mm-hmm-hmm
let's go forward man okay let me
remissed if I didn't ask you about your
bromance with Diplo whether it's
catching a Phillies game or exploring
the Swiss Alps with your shirts off or
hitting the beach on vacation you guys
seem to do everything together I feel
like my tongue is gonna start not being
able to articulate what I want it like
for words where should I keep going
he's it's so bad yeah you're telling me
we keep drinking my milk what's the
biggest misconception about Diplo you
think what do people get wrong about him
that he's not an innovator I feel like
some people may say that sometimes which
is weird I mean it's crazy that he just
he's always on that next hip hop thing
or that next dancehall thing or just
anything honestly taste level off the
waist level exactly and it's so it's
just inspiring to see that all the time
so I guess if anyone thinks that he's
not that was an isotonic burp of Table
one I feel like my nose is just gonna
start pouring out it's not so if it does
my bad oh man I don't want to eat this
one yeah
[Music]
remember how I'm like the second wing
you're like you need rules everybody's
got to eat all the way and then like how
round like man I want to throw this away
so I'm trying not to be a little [ __ ]
about it and I just realized the milk is
a bad idea it takes all the sauce off
the wing turns into liquid puts liquid
heat on my throat but what's the
alternative you know not go with the
milk yeah hard to do it's almost
impossible to do oh there it is
yeah so despite all the drama and
infighting that you see an EDM much to
your credit you really seem like the
junior high kid that can sit at any
table in the cafeteria so what I want to
do is hit you with some yearbook
superlatives and you can tell me which
DJ best fits the description okay but
best dressed a few mark ronson or DJ
snake DJ snakes got like the athletic
version down most likely to succeed in
something besides DJ I feel like Martin
garrix is up there if he wasn't DJing he
would still be doing some cool [ __ ] he'd
be finding in the Netherlands on some in
GQ magazine Netherlands biggest drama
King jaws jaws is a drama king his
Twitter sorry jaws but you little [ __ ]
sometimes he he like is always like
complaining about something that's very
niche like it's about like when when
it's like man the planes not on time
right right and everyone has problems
relate to that not that's the most
unrelatable thing I've ever heard who
gives a [ __ ] to biggest flirt biggest
flirt Diplo for sure
the heat from my mouth is causing my
brain to not function that well
oh we dab one right yes all right Dylan
so this is the last dab it is called the
last dab because it's a tradition around
here to put a little dab on the last
wing you don't have to I'll do it if you
don't want Anna feeling that's where
this was going there you go dab it
cheers Cheers doing what a run it's been
it's been great do you go for this
nevermind uh-huh ooh
I like this one already that's a green
sauce mustard action
by the way all I've had today is coffee
so my stomach is about to Joe be so mad
rookie mistake
I know I was about to get a sandwich
from Starbucks downstairs but then I was
I didn't want to be late I wanted to be
a publishable punctual nice human being
total Pro bad idea I can't feel him
mouth mm-hm so that's good you ever just
top it off what's the top it off you
just like take a little dab just maybe
like maybe this is the way you deal with
that in the last step it's by chasing it
was racing less intense hots yes in the
hopes that act kind of steals the chair
yeah I mean it'll last at the beginning
that's it's an interesting move
so Todd seen this one yet who knows what
will work coat the mouth with it
[Music]
my work like work I think I made you
just like a exacerbated the situation
all right Dylan
this is the last wing I have one more
question for you we're going one deeper
yeah this one because I want to talk to
you about a catchphrase that stuck with
you your whole career
it's idgaf OS for the uninitiated I
don't give a [ __ ] or [ __ ] I think is a
brilliant life philosophy and so here's
what I wonder what is your best piece of
advice for how people can apply this
ideology to their lives how do you think
a world would be better place if
everyone adopted and no [ __ ] given
attitude there's certain things to give
[ __ ] about but most of its most of it
was for you know not caring about what
anybody is saying about either your
style whatever you're doing whatever
you're making whatever you're trying to
create whatever you want to do online
whatever you want to do in real life do
your thing
don't let anyone get in the way be
spirited and happy along the whole thing
and you know don't give a [ __ ] ur [ __ ]
what anybody thinks Dillon Francis you
look good
I can tell that you feel good when you
put your arm up no perspiration
whatsoever
how amazing this camera this camera are
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life I have a new
song coming out soon with young pinch
just finish the world with Diplo do show
is the best show on YouTube [ __ ] the
vlog
that was fantastic I hate myself my body
is gonna really just be so angry later
Oh God oh I got milk and hot sauce just
build a life out of me
hello world Sean Evans coming at you to
say thank you for watching if you liked
what you saw please subscribe
we're hovering around the three
thousandth ranked youtube channel in the
world it has been a childhood dream of
mine to be somewhere in the mid twos
we're so close help make an adult bald
man's dreams come true please please
please jk jk no pressure but if you do
subscribe I appreciate it